what's up guys Greg here
nothing beats getting a bed laid awake
enough to take up tests and then finding
out to store ragnarok trailer drops okay
introduction complete
[Music]
whoa well I know what you're thinking
how does this happen
[Music]
long story
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
what if you brush today tell me
oh ho it main event time where is it
[Music]
oh we know each other
Oh
[Music]
sweet oh snap diggity guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 have never looked better
ah God you just know from right Roger
like everyone a lot Billy wheeler Corden
fujoshi drew yeah you can't blame the
people for saying that because it
definitely does have like the gene gun
vibe throughout that trailer I like the
80s credits kind of touch to it as well
I mean they got like a rock and roll but
Zeppelin the song over the trailer we
were come on this movie looks really fun
of it and it definitely looks different
than the first couple of course of
course this is happening right when I
start filming and they had no [__]
noise the whole time I really like to
turn it I look like a lot of fun paint
Blanchett I think they're the cares name
you up she looks [__] sexy man she
took scary and sexy and we've no keep
watching is good at doing both of those
things but that beginning of the trailer
when she when she catches the owner and
then just destroys it that's a great
setup for a villain it's the owner you
know like everyone I think anyone thinks
of me Omar now thinks about the scene in
age of Ultron they're all trying to pick
up the hammer and with oars
indestructible awesome hammer and then
she [__] destroys it right at the
beginning of this trailer that's a great
setup for a villain and a great way to
put Thor in a position of you know he he
has to just be a warrior in this film
because he doesn't have his trusty
hammer that he relies on so much to
defeat bad guys it's already putting me
as a viewer in a position of how is Thor
going to defeat this person but with a
lot of the designs you know what the
intergalactic space designs with the
ships and the other characters this is
one of the other Marvel stories where if
it looks a little bit like guarding the
galaxy they kind of doesn't bother me
because this takes place another world a
different part of the universe you know
so if it's space travel adventure
happening if it happens to look and feel
a little bit like Gardens the galaxy I'm
a little okay with that because it's
triggered it has like good battles and
[__] going on in it and I think where is
it I think I like that here it is one
out 104 it looks like call a car over
yeah Karl Urban
I think cares named scourge is him
firing like assault rifles through them
in the air which I hear is not something
people would ever do in real life
according to a CIA training I did a long
time ago but anyway he's fired he's
armored up like one of the types of
warriors from the Thor movies yet he's
firing the two assault rifles so this
[__] looks pretty [__] crazy man and
then you know everyone's really looking
forward to the gladiator battle the one
between Hulk and Thor and I love the
moment when Hulk showed up because hoax
shows up we're all waiting for the for
them to tease the moment where they're
gonna have to battle each other but he
shows up and Thor super excited and he
knew each other like that was such a
funny as a moment I really liked it I
like how he decided to keep the fun
about it instead of trying to do like a
super serious vs. moment he was looking
forward to the fact that he can fight
him he's being put in the gladiator
position but now he's excited that he
gets to fight Hulk that was a really
cool moment I'm interested to see the
storyline of how Bruce Banner got here
you know cuz velocity song was an age of
Ultron and he's just flying off but now
he's in this other part of the universe
I'm definitely very intriguing I'm
excited to see a different side of Thor
without his hammer looks like they're
sending up a really cool villain if you
know the MCU has a tough time with
having badass villains and just from the
little bit of footage they start off the
trailer with the villain and the villain
does something that makes me go wow
that's a pretty scary villain I don't
know how that health or can defeat this
person so I'm interested to see what he
has to do Smith oh sorry guys to work
together with you know Loki Hulk hemmed
all the rest of the game you know he's
going to have to use his YouTube uses
leadership skills and also use his
skills as just Thor the warrior without
his hammer
oh yeah kind of like Iron Man with
student Iron Man 3 everyone's favorite
Marvel installment it looks like they're
reinventing the image of Thor giving it
a much more humorous life and honestly
when you get a director like ty EQI
TT I think is his name when you get a
director like him who's known for comedy
I am not surprised and when you see
those viral videos where you know Thor
is has a roommate Penny's living on
earth that are just so [__]
hysterical it makes sense that this
would have a much more comedic you know
level to it we get little moments of
Tesla thompson's Valkyrie which a lot of
people are very excited for her
character I personally don't know much
about her she looks cool in it actually
had a hot badass black chick in this
movie hell yeah for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and well I thought Jeff
Goldblum's Grand Master looked a little
silly just from though you know the
still they release in Entertainment
Weekly about seeing him a little bit
more movement with the lighting the
cinematography and the world the
atmosphere that we have set up here it
looks significantly less silly and I'm
excited to see what Jeff Goldblum does a
little Sam Neill supposed to be in this
movie to get rid of Jurassic Park
reunion and and so is Benedict
Cumberbatch as you know Caan is supposed
to be in here as well and last thing I
wanted I'm curious to see what role
Loki's playing here because it looks
like Loki might be like helping the bad
guys in this one at first I wasn't too
sure which side he was fighting on the
images showed of him fighting they even
had a quick little snippet before Thor
see he's about to fight the Hulk you see
Loki sitting on the same couch as the
Grandmaster when that battle was
happening and like they look they look
like they're treating Loki with a
respect and a sense of authority and
hierarchy he doesn't look like he's a
prisoner like Thorin I'm not sure what
when Loki has up his sleeve here if he's
going to do something to aid his brother
Thor in the end but you know it's Tom
Hiddleston's Loki the best character out
of the whole MCU the villain this I
think could be a good direction for the
Thor films Thor the dark world was a was
not a very good film according to a lot
of people I personally
most people I know think it's one of the
worst of the MCU films to death or films
can use a different direction to go on
and I'm liking what I'm seeing and I'm
really enjoying the fun flair to it
cuber humor you know you don't want to
go to directors it comes with movies
these days intensive set people for some
reason kind of nothing solid really but
I I like it so see people getting upset
from this trailer just because it's such
a different vibe it is reminiscent of
guardians of the galaxy but I'm enjoying
that the Thor movie looks like it's
taking advantage of a space opera vibe
because it looks like you have elements
of you know the fantasy stuff because
besides you know seeing spaceships in
show you got different kinds of
creatures if you got a shot where a
woman with Halle Berry Valkyrie was
riding a giant eagle at one point I love
the inclusion of like you know Lord of
the Rings meets guardians of the galaxy
combined into one this looks really
sweet to me how the hell is Doctor
Strange gonna fit into all this
alright subscribe to the real rejects
follow me on instagram and twitter at
the greg alba and shout out to the DC
universe i i'll still watch your movies
too don't worry